Eric Palacios from Eric Palacios and
Associates shares what the traffic laws
are regarding emergency vehicles and
school buses in today's legal minute
hi I'm attorney Eric Palacios welcome to
the legal minute today's question is
what are the traffic laws regarding
emergency vehicles and school buses
first always yield to an emergency
vehicle that has its lights on or sirens
on pull over to your right as soon as
possible don't pull over to the left or
don't simply stop in the middle of the
road if there is a raised median in the
emergency vehicle is coming in the
opposite direction Most states do not
require you to pull over unless there is
a break in the median where the
emergency vehicle can cross over into
your lane next come to a stop if you see
a school bus with the stop signs
activated whether you're going in the
same or opposite direction of the bus
stop until the stop sign is retracted
and there are no more children on the
street this has been the legal minute if
you have any questions you can call our
office at
702-444-7777
that information again for Palacios and
Associates
702-44-777 or you can go to their
website at Eric palacioslaw.com
problem